[Music]
[Applause]
yes
how are you feeling very good yeah steve
what's the menu scallops
quills egg and uh crispy pancetta crispy
pancakes
christmas pancetta
uncle festive what's the main course
don't say that i'm not gonna
[Laughter]
meet tonight's family brigade the
mcguinnesses
backing paddy up in the kitchen is tony
a former casino pit manager
who at 16 stone clearly loves stacking
up the chips
then there's omaran also known as emu
steve might be a former professional
footballer but he's got two left feet in
the kitchen
comedian paddy clearly loves a laugh but
the f-word diners won't find it funny if
the food's not up to scratch
if they don't like it they don't pay
on the menu tonight pan soda scholars
with quail's eggs and pancetta
a scallop of chicken with fresh tomatoes
and mozzarella
and raspberry souffle any pissing about
and the lads will be on the road to
nowhere [ __ ] you ramsey
yeah starter pan sauteed
scallop quails eggs crispy pancetta
pancetta and a really nice fresh
pea puree these things are delicate the
secret is opening it up properly yeah
the best thing to do is just slice and
then with your nails
just open that up and nice and gently
lay it in there
now the secret behind the dish there's
no big sauce and involved is quite
healthy
we've got the p puree the bottom of the
plate and we want the nice rich
quail egg yolk combining as a bit of a
sauce patty you're looking very confused
what's the matter no
wrong concept yeah good man what's the
exit done have the constant take them
off
i let them sit there by six scallops and
the idea now
is just seasoning from a height and that
gets a really nice even
distribution okay we start at 12 o'clock
work our way around
so we know which one needs to be turned
first
now honestly literally 30 seconds in
turn 30 seconds the other side if you
ever cook them they go really rubbery
puree yeah this is blended yeah with
chicken stock okay so bring the chicken
top of the ball
pee straight in cook for a little 30
seconds seasoned then blitzed okay
now one on five
see like little miss muffet's sat on a
tuffet yeah three nice quartz eggs
and then a little bit of vinegar on
there yeah that acts as a bit of a sauce
pancetta on the end okay could you play
for that time yeah yeah yeah of course
if every dish goes out like that yeah
trust me you'll get 50 out of 50 pain
for that yeah yeah
sections let's have steve and paddy
together tony
home run together the two chunkies down
there end and stephen paddy
gentlemen are we ready yes yes yes yes
four covers table twelve four scallops
four chicken for souffle
yes chef yeah sure cool [ __ ] slight
delayed reaction
let's go now you yeah how many eggs
you're putting in three three
quail eggs and four portions on right so
how many is that all together
three four sorry golden four and four
golden eagle
four threes are what 12 how many eggs
you put on
uh [ __ ] you now paddy
have a word i'm not i'm not listening to
12.
now we look at me plus one extra okay
smash talking boys
let's go let's go let's go time for
jenna street farmer to see if the
british public are ready for veal
last week janet took her calves david
and elton to the local primary school
to help educate the next generation of
meat eaters about the delights of
british rose veal
she's got the kids on side but now it's
time to tackle the adults
[Music]
the quiet market town of ripon is in the
heart of traditional yorkshire beef
country
there's no one here but is it ready for
the culinary atom bomb that is janet
street porter
don't all right i've missed your bloody
cheese stool by mile
and her friend jane their mission
to set up a british veal stall at the
farmers market in a bid to convert the
locals to the great flavour of veal
but of course she's going to do it janet
style excuse me
can you help us don't look at me like
look
[Music]
on the menu veal burgers and veal stew
i'll attempt you with some veal stew
but even here in rural ripon janet's got
a mountain to climb
sorry the difference between veal and
venison medicine
is a deer
it's time for a veal education when the
cows give birth
to male calves the female calves are
kept for breeding
but the male calves have been sent to
the continent for veal
where they're raised in much worse
conditions than they are here
that'd be gorgeous getting yours around
that
i didn't know enough about it to be
honest and i just learned that
they're killed at the same age that
lambs are as well so i'd buy
feel better mcdonald's anyway i've been
cooking with britishville for years
i believe it's a huge waste not to eat
this delicious meat
you like it you're not just liking it
because it's fresh
janet seems to be making headway with
the people of yorkshire but back at the
barn
there's trouble brewing
david and elton have turned adolescent
they're bored
this is all they do what do you want
what they might need is television
and horny as their horns grow
so does the risk that they can seriously
injure each other livestock novice janet
needs help from an expert
oh joe thank god you're there listen
i've got a bit of a problem
they're growing horns
but like everything in the yorkshire
dales help moves at its own pace
now look at this look elton's got holes
i'm a bit worried about this is that
dangerous well
there are certain um worries that he's
getting quite bossy so
we could take them off if you like yeah
well is that what you do you take them
off to stop him
uh hurting the other animal because he
might
but david in the eye and lose an eye on
something like that it's a hot iron
which in about 30 seconds you just nip
off the top of the bud
yeah and that's it taking off the horn
buds is called disc budding
and it should stop the calves doing
serious damage to each other you sure he
can't feel anything
although it looks painful the calves
have been given a local anaesthetic
just like going to the dentist yeah
yeah there you go oh now look
the cars are healthy happy and disbudded
but there's a cloud on the horizon
good job there are only six weeks left
before janet
has to say goodbye what do you want you
guess grabbing me
janet good to see you again gordon as
always
now were you worried when elton and
david got horny
it was a bit worrying i am not going to
come out with any of the jokes no no no
no no
it wasn't sorry because they could have
injured each other
really frisky but i mean it looked
painful having that
it did but they had they had a local
anaesthetic what did it smell like
having the horns removed
you could smell the burning serious yeah
it was a bit
spooky but i didn't feel any pain at all
i mean recently
i had a bone spur removed from my
shoulder which is quite a normal
operation it wasn't a devil's horn
it was just a normal little bone and i
had the same thing where i had a local
anesthetic and i watched it on a tv
screen they just kind of shaved
it off you get normal cars every day i
thought they'd be
freaked by it but quite honestly they
were fine really they were fine it means
they can't injury each other yeah you're
getting
you're getting close to them i can see
it bonding has happened
yes don't get out of the box of kleenex
yet
first time you've ever had animals or
any form of emotional bonding with
anyone
no i've had husbands but they've come
and gone but they've never lasted this
long ever
listen i'm going to take them to be
slaughtered and i'm going to give
i thought you had already they passed
their sale by date charlie
always a pleasure yeah look after the
boys yes i will yes
good to see you sure you don't want to
be at this buddy
get some tissue on there quickly yes yes
that's why the eggs are poaching
keep that for your head come on okay so
yeah okay
i need some eggs we haven't run out of
eggs have we
the hottest are you getting more eggs
they're two carrots have you checked out
eggs
even bastards seriously really enough
eggs in here for 80 [ __ ] portions
how many of you pinned i've not been
down here yeah i mean
let's go stephen get your plates out
quickly paddy
yeah so i have an extra slice of scallop
per portion no [ __ ] eggs yes
extra slices proportion yeah [ __ ] you
now
place these scallops just first follow
me yeah no not just one scallop get on
there
let's go i have to extremely apologize
because this is how far as they could
actually get it out so
where's my eggs they kind of run out of
their queer legs so
yeah now [ __ ] uh okay clear down yeah
let's get ready for the main course
how are you sir ladies good evening
we're gentlemen how are we
very well good now how was your starter
fantastic yeah you enjoy it
really difficult the flavors the
textures fantastic all right really well
why are you looking so miserable the
arm's falling what's the matter
everything was done perfectly right
that's just too much
that plate does look pretty old you're
absolutely right and they're supposed to
be finished with a little drizzle of
vinaigrette so obviously something's
very heavy-handed with the vinaigrette
so
okay damn they give you a puddle not a
drizzle which is a shame donnie how was
yours
perfect it really was yeah something you
could try at home thank you
i'd be brave i would give it a go i'm
glad here hope you enjoy the main course
good to see you
really nice mixture of flavors and
textures as well
okay how well do you think you did start
us we stared at the crap and we're gonna
go better yeah
yeah right jose results please thank you
right
the number of people yeah that are
willing to pay for the starter out of 15
is 35 out of 50.
hey it's not perfect but it's not bad
now get ready to crack on the main
course let's go
coming up funnyman paddy reveals what he
does for a laugh
every hole's a goal gone
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
nice time for be generous tomorrow's
come on can you do it i'll be doing it
you're welcome welcome back to the f
word time for the main course it's
colorful chicken with fresh tomatoes and
mozzarella
come on guys skeleton chicken with
sweaty potatoes and red chard one of my
favorite all-time
birds chicken breast butterfly if it's
open
the whole thing cooks evenly egg wash
beet flour season
chicken breast dust shake off any excess
flour
into the egg wash just run it through
and then into the breadcrumbs this helps
to keep the chicken breast really nice
and moist
hot pan olive oil into the pan
color turn it over that's what we want
rest sauce shallots
garlic tomatoes hot pan olive oil
basil
[Music]
sauce mozzarella grated parmesan
olive oil stop it from going dry bake
eight minutes look at that
beautiful
[Applause]
it's gollop of chicken served with
sauteed potatoes and red chard
done
nothing's happening with these uh
scallops you're gonna gotta cook them
with some gas
some heat in there yeah yeah get a few
more tomatoes in there two more pastas
chef
oh [ __ ] sorry that's right for those
right
tonight's recipes you know where they
are get going let's go
so in the early days it used to be an 18
to 30 club rep yeah yeah yeah what were
the perks
well yeah obviously you know a couple
like a blind couple of spots
at the end of it but uh you know how
many times do you catch crabs
uh just the wall just to watch i thought
you can only catch them
the attitude game magazine proved you
the number two second
eligible bachelor yeah is that right
yeah huh how did that make you feel
every hole's a goal go on you know that
oh yeah
you've got to work as a team now yeah
yeah sure yeah
good pumps and cheese how's your feet
and in the oven now yeah quicker
that's yours right let's do the garnish
now yes right
time for catfish looks [ __ ] ugly but
tastes amazing
this is oklahoma one of the many places
in america where catfish is high on the
menu
it has a similar taste to cod or halibut
and the rivers lakes and swamps of the
american south
are crawling with this delicious fish
this little beauty here
is cotton chips to the locals it's the
most amazing phillips of catfish they've
been coated in cornmeal
lightly fried and they taste absolutely
[ __ ] delicious
you can only buy farmed catfish in
oklahoma if you want to experience the
taste of it wild
you need to catch them yourself oh mr
ramsay hi sir
i'm going to be taught to noodle for
mine by local champion lee mcfarlane
i'm excited to be here noodling tell me
what it's but it's an
act of getting in the water and catching
giant catfish with your bare hands
what's the chances of being bitten
be like a pit bull ready when he grabs
hold of you he'll bite you and make you
say words you haven't said in a long
time
you can't noodle on your own so we're
taking the family with us it'll be like
fishing with the waltons
but hopefully their expertise will
ensure we grab a decent catch
[Music]
this is lee's prized patch carl
blackwell lake
a stretch of water six miles long and
four miles wide
the clay turns the water a murky orange
color which makes what i'm about to do
ten times harder now usually i'd cast
the line out
and wait all day for a bite hoping to
land a big [ __ ] catfish but
here on this lake they noodles so
basically all you need is a big pair of
hands and a big pair of bollocks
this lake is teaming with catfish and
lee knows it like the back of his hand
we're heading to his best noodling spots
with cousin mark and his
so son-in-law do we see them you won't
see them they'll be like
feeling in the dark flying yeah and that
the minute it steps first time
bang hold up grab hold of it catfish
hide in cracks and holes below the
surface
the native americans thought grabbing
them by hand was the best way to find
food
and people have been noodling here ever
since
[Applause]
first we need to find the holes on the
bed of the lake using our feet
it's quite a big hole now isn't it a
little scared it's quite eerie
i can't see [ __ ] all right yeah i ain't
got to see jeremy i'm and i'm using my
feet and my hands
and i'm like fishing blind you're
hunting
surrounded by bushland the lake is full
of black snakes and snapping turtles
i'm wearing gloves to prevent my fingers
being bitten off whilst to go under and
dig deep
nothing else down there nothing else is
in there we don't check
by going underwater i could reach as far
into the holes as possible
long way back there isn't it feel how
big that hole gets
yes big it's big all the way through
we also check holes in the river banks
which are easier to get to
but just as dangerous it just feels so
strange that you're handing a [ __ ]
halt waiting for chris to bite you so
you can grab it by the gills
and pull the [ __ ] out oh he's coming
to you bart he's right mark
leah's found our first catfish and is
attaching a rope through its mouth
underwater
to help stop it escaping holy man let's
see what you got
[ __ ] nice like that he then leads me
to do the hard bit
pulling the fish out of his hole [ __ ] i
see it
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bloody hell
but success is brief one minute is in my
hands and the next
it slips off the rope and gets away
sorry guys that's part of the game
another hour another location on the
lake
and in less than 20 minutes leah's found
another one fill that hole under there
this time it wasn't going anywhere you
had to go under yeah
he's there you got him yep oh [ __ ] now
he's just bit me
[ __ ]
that's a good one we are going to eat
fish
the bigger the catfish the tastier the
flesh and these boys will tell you
this is by far the best way to bag a
decent catch
oh [ __ ] me is the big one look at that
beauty lovely
and our catch was proof i was fishing
with some of the best noodlers in the
business
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
jesus guys there's some weight now
good job we'll cut their tails let them
bleed
ready yeah cause if you don't you'll
have a lot of blood in that meat
yeah that's like we do to a pig huh
that's amazing i never knew you had to
drain them
and your father showed you this way my
father taught me all this
[ __ ] ryan i've learned how to noodle
properly now i've got to skim one
and then fill it one to skin one yeah
what you've got if you look right here
you just barely want to pierce the skin
here's the next thing
just like catching them lee makes
skinning the catfish look easy
now it's my turn under the bow turf in
modern day times [ __ ] pair of pliers
and a pin knife
going down like taking your socks off
there you go unbelievable now he's ready
to play look how white that flesh is
but if we wouldn't have cut the tail
yeah that'd been all solid red down
through there
you want it as white as that because
it's so tough
so why are they so cheap because they're
they're raising them in ponds
these are wild the taste is a lot
different because these are bigger
see i just think everyone's got the
wrong impression for catfish you know
that they do
these are the best eating from that big
mother that
is delicious freshly noodle catfish
skinned filleted and now we're going to
cook them cajun style
i'm making a delicious fiery marinade
using paprika cayenne pepper and dried
thyme
that makes the fish a lot more fragrant
a tablespoon of garlic powder
season with salt pepper and olive oil
the juice of two lemons
helps to season the fish and more
importantly it works the marinade a lot
quicker
give that a little mix from there
roll the catfish around the marinade
already the catfish is starting to
absorb that marinade and then from there
heat the pan nice and hot olive oil in
get some colour on the catfish to seal
it and give it some flavor
that's what we want there that really
nice blackened flavour
and that's why it's cajun style
these layers of white wine to take the
kick out of the spices and to keep the
fish moist
and then from there i'm gonna make our
vinaigrette two parts olive oil
fresh lemon juice salt pepper and a
tablespoon of white wine vinegar
a little pinch of dried thyme nice
mix that up on a touch of vinegar over
there
before the catfish comes out a nice drop
fresh lemon beautiful look at that
lovely out onto the plate once the
catfish has cooled down
all i'm going to do now is just get the
catfish and just
open up and look at that really nice
blackened flavor on the outside lay
inside the lettuce and that has to be
the most amazing
way of eating catfish right you redneck
noodles you ready
excellent that's delicious and fast huh
and fast and healthy mmm the flavour
the flavor the catfish is extraordinary
you normally fry yours
this josh is a an alternative a lot
healthier so
next time you're noodling you can fit
down all those little cracks
yeah please redeem himself guys am i
officially a redneck now
you're redneck thank you that's one trip
i'll never forget i can assure you
seven tables to go seven seven come on
we're gonna start playing number six now
yeah
right paddy keep an eye on your tomato
sauce come on we can do this yeah
stephen
tony you're staying on four now okay he
can't [ __ ] count above five so i'm
not gonna give him six
you can do in yeah counter mean 24 in
french then queer please
um see what knee
death that's german you're [ __ ] smart
yes how did you and peter k meet we went
school together
me and pete in the same year seriously
can you imagine the [ __ ] t-shirts
they
the hard time they got yeah i told you
when you met uh oh god would be 11.
seriously and i got into comedy because
i saw peter at a club and he
he said i was getting me weighed he got
40 quid and i thought i don't earn that
in a shift what are we doing in town so
that's what made me get interested in
the money
bolton's are not better talent gordon
okay guys
last two tables yes yes yeah here we go
come on guys we can see the finishing
line
ah in you get them get them come on
let's go come on boy
lovely lovely lovely yeah go go go go go
go go go out she goes
well done well done
50 dinosaurs
good to see you how was your chicken
really nice yeah something you could do
at home
yeah yeah i think so yeah the potatoes
where the chilis were nice left a nice
bit of warmth at back at throat very
nice nice
beautiful chicken can be slightly bland
sometimes so a fresh tomato sauce
with mozzarella tomatoes never choose
chicken in a restaurant really but that
was so
tasty i love the cheese and the lots of
the tomato and the chicken but i think
the chili was a little bit too
overpowered for the
yeah good to see you thank you
well i thought the chicken was really
well seasoned it's very flavoursome
good garlic taste to it potatoes are
pretty zingy which i liked
the spice of the potatoes is kind of
overpowering
the rest of the taste at the moment but
chicken is delicious very crispy
reducing really good right results from
the main in you
[Laughter]
[ __ ] up now i thought yeah you did
[ __ ] well
the difference on the main course from
the starter was phenomenal
thank you thank you thank you okay and i
hope that reflects in the results you
know that right jose
let's go right out of 50 diners yeah the
number they're paying for the main
course
46 out of 50.
out of 15. bloody well done
now 50 out of 50 for desserts absolutely
fantastic that
tony and emu really pulled out their bag
after the starters
unbelievable when it comes together and
gordon's developing
and you're working and you're not going
like your head's lost it's perfect
that's absolutely fantastic when you get
dishes out like that
your heart's beating and you feel great
that's something i remembered at school
he said i counted in german it wasn't
earned to our cultural sciences
roasting the chicken for one guy there
we're going to start that one grid
lingual
dara brienne tries to impress me with
his food knowledge play play
play play play
oh [ __ ] the stones come out
right welcome back to the f-word now my
next challenger is used to singing for a
supper jamilia
welcome are you ready yes i'm very are
you excited yes i am what are you
cooking
i'm making a jamaican chicken soup look
at you what was the last time you
practiced it
i don't practice it's something i cook
nearly every saturday i like that it's
in your blood
yes so talk me through the dish how's it
work you're putting chicken in your bag
i'm just gonna put all the spices in
kind of like a
a marinade and one thing i don't measure
anything i'm kind of a talented cook
yes paprika garlic powder um curry
powder
brown sugar and this is tomato ketchup
not a traditional
i know i'm going to win ketchup jamaica
worcestershire sauce
nice you know so you put it all in the
bag and then boil it
and no i'm gonna fry it first can i just
give you a message
yes please from my other half he said if
you swear at me or shout at me he's
going to come here and rip your teeth
okay turn the [ __ ] off what's his name
who's he played for bristol city bless
him i mean being such an amazing wag
couldn't you pick the premiership
footballer i'm not a wag
you're dating a footballer a wig is a
description from someone who's not me
excuse me yeah but i could have bought
them myself
okay so the name of this is what's it
called saturday soup
saturday yeah but if you're saying
okay so jamina's making saturday soup
sounds beautiful and i'm gonna make a
spicy chicken soup very similar
using sweet potatoes chicken chili
starinis a little bit of soy sauce
onions garlic and finish it with a bit
of coconut milk not too spicy
so i'm basically just browning the
chicken here i'm not um
you know i'm not attempting to cook it
um that smells delicious already
yeah i'm getting nervous now yeah ryan
spent off my red onions and chilli
teaspoon of mixed ground spice a couple
of star in these
three of those and a little touch of
garlic
first record deal at 15. first child at
20. how did you manage that
manic schedule juggling you know what i
believe in
having a positive mental attitude and if
you really want to do something then
you will that's why you weren't put off
by bristol city he's not exactly my
united liverpool
he wasn't actually playing for bristol
city when i met him who was he playing
house
jesus christ okay onions
garlic chili sweated off sweet potato
chicken starinis
and now from there i'm gonna put a
couple of tablespoons
of sesame seed oil in there and sweat
the chicken off
with two tablespoons of soya sauce
um okay well so far i've browned the
chicken um i've put my dumplings
in there now being a british born
jamaican
i'm using the mixer usually we'd have to
knead the dumplings for 10 minutes
but um i haven't done that i'm now
cutting up the pumpkin i've put the
green bananas into simmering
hot water because i've cooked this a
million times before
gordon's out of his deck and i'd be very
very embarrassed if i lose
where did you learn to cook because you
enjoy it don't you i
absolutely love cooking and i i learned
to cook
just i think they're watching my mom and
my nan
and yeah i have got a couple of your
wife's books
very good better than yours the books
are [ __ ]
no they're not don't be so horrible
that's your wife you're supposed to be
supporting her can i just
point out i've taken off my engagement
ring just because i know my other half
is going to see me without it and he's
going to know what have you taken off
you know have i fallen in love with
gordon
how many carrots two points something
another i don't know
beautiful thank you absolutely beautiful
thank you
oh [ __ ] the stone's come out no
seriously no no no i didn't
get it from one thing like that because
i've got these bloody grazies on my
finger
that is beautiful thank you
get back to your station oh come on
i
right that looks nice from here yeah are
you going to put your [ __ ] soup in there
is that
cocksuit what is that it is huh mine's
finished
mine's finished is it i'm gonna finish
my little bit of mint
fresh mint that you're gonna spoil it i
wouldn't suggest you put that in and put
mint in now
yeah right both chicken soups need 15 to
20 minutes to simmer
jamila goes off does a little bit of
karaoke comes back and loses are you
ready whatever
whatever yeah you're going down
i believe you can cook healthy food
wherever you are and whatever you're
doing
i'm away working from home i often find
it hard to eat well
imagine what it's like for irish
comedian dara o'brien who finds himself
at a different venue
every night of his 72-day uk tour
danny what do you do i own my own shoe
repairing car you own your own shoe
repairing company
you have a little hammer do you have a
guy in the window one of those things in
the window do you have one of them
ah no not anymore not anymore what
happened what did he expose himself to
some children inappropriately
that's a lot of bad eating for this
hard-working comedian
i'm here in derby city centre to meet
dara where he's performing his stand up
live tonight at this assembly rooms
more importantly i'm dying to find out
what kind of food he eats whilst he's on
tour
dara why are you sir well thank you how
are you i'm very well
good to see you man good to see you have
you been on stage i've never been on
stage i'll show you a stage with nobody
in us this is what's
the worst thing right now two two and a
half hour show it's about two and a half
hours yeah
it reminds me a little bit like a
service in the kitchen from seven
o'clock first table to ten o'clock is
live do you know what's a bit like
it is the only culinary way to do it's a
bit like plates spinning
see that block there at the front yeah
right i'll go to that guy that guy
maybe a woman there and a guy over there
yeah i've got a roaster roasting a
chicken for one guy there we're gonna
start that one griddling up
it's like the main course with five
different garnishes you'll bring
together the same time but you've got to
go back to them
and the thing is there is a point where
i deliver all the dishes yeah where i am
play play
play play play which is at the very end
where everything that happens
yeah i gotta stick a bow in the whole
tank what do you eat either i am
grabbing a very quick
pizza express or i am in burger king
you know what you look at subway as if
it's a holy grail because at least it's
vegetable
if there's time to go and buy a takeaway
there's time to cook a healthy meal
wherever you are every town has a market
and just around the corner from the
assembly rooms is market hall
bursting with fresh produce i never see
this stuff no
open normally six seven days a week just
freshness and fresh fresh fresh
fresh herbs everything you want
everything perfect that there is quite
nice that do you want this
parsley taste rosemary mint um
that's chervil that's sure of them that
was almost my next one this is gonna be
the best nice steak i've ever had no
behave yourself you're not having snakes
[Music]
thank you sir all right that sounds good
we're done i'm going to show dara how to
cook a tasty dish that will help get him
in shape for his long gruelling tours
it's dead easy to cook at home and even
if he only cooks it once a week on the
road
it will still make a big difference
well here i am in our home uh kitchen we
built this which you've never [ __ ]
seen before in your entire life now
we're not doing steak
i know you're craving for a steak we're
not doing curry okay something you've
never done before
a really nice delicious tiger prawn
pilaf okay spicy because i know you like
it quite hot
cooked in one pot it's easy and quick
and it's light but it'll keep him going
all night on stage
let's do it together begin by chopping
two red onions
take your time i am taking my time good
grate some garlic
i'm trying to make it easy for you you
cooking it on your own is easy for me
i have a machine at home and zest two
lemons
add fresh thyme take as much time as you
want
come on come on
chop up some chorizo which will help to
add a rich flavor
half a teaspoon of cayenne pepper in
this one very nice what is it no idea i
have a blocked nose but it looks great
saffron oh is that saffron that's
saffron fresh saffron yeah
in in comparison we had to eat last
night this will be a big difference
yeah i'd stay classy
cinnamon stick
heat some olive oil and place everything
in the pan start stirring
we want to break down that chorizo yeah
[Music]
stir in the pillow rice that's it the
nice thing about this we've got the fish
stock up to the ball now
we're sealing the rice off so the whole
thing cooks a lot quicker
pour your stock into the rice that's the
noise you want
this is called a cartouche cover and put
in the oven
200 degrees eight to ten minutes but
this time i would have sat down i'd be
reading a paper
i would have chosen the pizza in terms
of calories yes oh yeah listen with it
this is clearly going to be taking
protein
healthy and more importantly 20 minutes
last thing peel the prawns which are low
in fat but rich in protein iron and zinc
[Music]
so here's the nice thing about this dish
look no stress
it cooks itself from there mix in your
tiger prawns
[Music]
mix in chop chervil and basil back in
the oven for five minutes to cook the
prawns
just enough time to get my moment in the
spotlight ladies and gentlemen please
welcome on stage
[Music]
[Applause]
jesus christ that's bright no yeah so
hello
get up hold on give me two minutes two
minutes i'll do the warm up i'll do the
one
hold on a minute is that what the
tickets cost 40 pound each is that
include dinner
we've got that really nice flavor from
the cinnamon it's fragrant
yeah that smells nice
it does smells much better than a
[ __ ] burger i'm loving this
it's absolutely fantastic and you know
what i'll i'll go home and i'll try to
cook this
i suppose i'm trying to um get across
more than anything um it tastes
delicious
it does it's healthy and it's so
straightforward one pot wonder
i just wish you've eaten [ __ ]
properly now all right all right all
right
god it's like it's i'm gonna be mother
jesus i'm in a treadmill now i got
treadmill for you behind this
okay off we go let's go nice so when you
start mixing these the secret behind
this
is getting a really good stiff peak yeah
good you've really got to work that ball
around
gotta be really vigorous with it oh man
yeah let me scan a bit before you
right from there look up fold in that's
nice
the egg whites are perfect yeah that's
ninety percent the battle done
right cut one of my favorite desserts
raspberry souffle
[Music]
raspberry souffle the number one show
off dessert now the secret with the
souffle is in the jam
hot pan sugar raspberries
vanilla as the sugar comes up to the
boil turn the gas down
and just let that cook out the jam is
nice and rich but more importantly we
want to get rid of the seeds but we want
to push
all that jam through the sieve into the
fridge
cool it down paste your cream cream and
milk into the pan
bring that up to the boil egg yolks
sugar
beet flour
that helps to thicken the pastry cream
mix
you want that really nice smooth texture
the cream and milk
come up to the boil this is where it
gets really exciting whisk that up
and then put your custard back in to the
pan
as you cook it out it gets nice and
thick
and that's it into a bowl mix
into the fridge and cool the pastry
cream down
now buttering the moulds for the souffle
butter chocolate
and then just twist the mould
right jam's cooled down pastry creams
cool down add the jam to the pastry
cream
mix so it's nice and smooth rest
egg whites whisk
sugar egg whites
out mix
[Applause]
raspberries into a bowl raspy liqueur
raspberries at the bottom of the souffle
amaretti biscuits
that helps to absorb the alcohol one
nice scoop
in and bang down
that evenly places all the mixture
throughout the raspberries in the
biscuit and just run
a little circle around the mould that
helps the souffle to rise
into the oven 190 degrees 10 minutes
icing sugar that has to be the perfect
way of showing off
at a dinner party [ __ ] beautiful
raspberry souffle
done
right keep it going guys yes don't
overfill the moulds otherwise they'll
explode
good little bit harder cloth underneath
look cloth there bang bang bang
a little bit harder to see and you see
the air bubbles come up now there you go
all right totally
make sure those molds are nice and clean
yes yes yes good man
if they go in there dirty they're gonna
come out like dirty
[ __ ] bits of cake [ __ ] well done
stevie really good
thank you chef hey stevie yeah you start
eight more now yeah get your bowl
cleaned
yeah look come here [ __ ] now let's
see i'm trying to help you [ __ ] l.a
look there's more on the outside than
the inside right ready for the first
table yeah here we go
beautiful a little uh a little dust of
ice and sugar
gotta serve them fast they start sinking
the minute they come out yes go go go go
go the table quickly
it looks like it's a little bit liquid
there yeah yeah what happened yeah
that's not right yeah start again that's
not right
off you go [ __ ] up right you open
so out straight away they're beautiful
very nice right start again
don't have the sugar until i come over
come on guys please no no no no the hot
[ __ ] hell yeah
so you've had a few jobs for your time
yeah yeah yeah what's the worst job
we've ever had
cleaning door for the bakery machines at
waterton's bread making factory
clean your day off bread making machines
yeah [ __ ] you now i think this job's
definitely suited to me now you know
i've found i've found what i like doing
where does the material come from how do
you think of it i just think it's just
stuff you you know you pick up along the
way
like this so definitely what you saw
absolutely serious yeah the accent helps
as well
oh yeah because it's quite a romantic
accent isn't it and
it's funny but if you swear in my accent
it's not as harsh as you swear in a
southern accent
no so i can see it [ __ ] you my friend
and he's quite funny and it sounds
charming it sounds charming
uh paddy here we go we're coming out the
other night yes yeah here we go
they're nice they're beautiful thank you
ah beautiful who put them in me yeah
well done
ah [ __ ] oh my god let's go quick nice go
come on [ __ ] off please play in your
hand come on let's go
well done oh hey okay clear down guys
yes
coming up it all kicks off when the
brigade find out the results for dessert
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the f word now time to
find out whose dish is top of the pops
are you ready yeah yeah
yes are you excited um a little bit
you're i i will be listing down the
whole nation if
this doesn't work out i know can we just
put them side by side i've got this
thing about sort of you know putting my
dish next to yours
mine looks a lot more rustic and yours
looks kind of quite
chefy oh gosh oh my god
proof is in the tasting take them away
good luck
you're horrible so
this is the first one and i have this
second over here
that's nice yeah really good really nice
sweet potatoes very good
very good it's spiced really nicely try
number two
yeah so the texture is much thinner it's
much runnier
oh it's got an instant kick it's less of
a curry flavor it's more of a
slightly oriental yeah right
nervous absolutely yours looked lovely
tasted
quite hot oh don't look at me like this
yeah no but look at your face
right what do they say they loved
jamilia's
caribbean flavors which they like best
who [ __ ] won they like gordon's best
yes
it was a ketchup how can you excuse me
it's not saturday it's tuesday yeah true
that's what
that's well done well done absolutely
brilliant
now do me a favor one more thing yes
welcome back to bristol
out bye bye bye big kiss
ladies how are we good to see you now
how was your souffle
delicious delicious [ __ ] mine as well
is your fringe a wig or is that just
fashion it's my phone
okay good before i tell you the results
yeah
i thought you did [ __ ] well on that
course you know well done right the
number of guests
that are happy to pay for dessert
is
48.50
so that's a grand total of 121 out of
150
sadly not good enough to come back but
you did [ __ ] well
that was a bolton
you